Окрім Брексіту,
перед Брюсселем нині постало ще, як мінімум,
5 викликів у внутрішній і зовнішній політиці.
Незадовго до саміту
на центральному вокзалі Брюсселя
поліція застрелила чоловіка з поясом смертника.
У Лондоні автофургон в'їхав у натовп людей перед мечеттю.
А в Парижі чоловік протаранив поліцейський автомобіль.
Загроза тероризму стала в Європі всюдисущою.
Тож у ЄС розробляють технології,
аби можна було автоматично розпізнавати
і видаляти в Інтернеті заклики до насильства.
Брюссель прагне стати більш незалежним від Вашингтона у сфері оборони.
Єврокомісія вже ініціює створення європейського оборонного фонду.
Він фінансуватиме розробку нових - виключно європейських - систем озброєнь.
Вже у поточному бюджеті ЄС
на це заплановано витратити до 2020-го року 90 мільйонів євро на дослідження
і ще півмільярда - на розробку.
В Євросоюзі наголошують:
це не означає перетворення ЄС
на альтернативу чи конкурента НАТО.
Євросоюз покращить зусилля для боротьби з глобальним потеплінням.
Рішення Дональда Трампа про вихід США з паризької кліматичної угоди -
лише  підштовхнуло країни ЄС
до активнішої і повнішої реалізації положень цього договору.
Сполучені Штати відмовляються робити внески до фонду допомоги країнам,
що розвиваються.
Брюссель же запевняє,
що і надалі фінансуватиме проекти
щодо захисту клімату.
ЄС працює над зміцненням берегової охорони в Лівії.
Мета - боротьба з нелегальними перевізниками мігрантів з Африки до Європи.
Крім того, Євросоюз буде проводити жорсткішу візову політику
щодо тих країн,
які відмовляються приймати назад своїх громадян,
висланих з ЄС.
Розбіжностей щодо продовження санкцій ЄС
проти Росії за анексію Криму та її дії на Сході України фактично немає.
Вони будуть продовжені ще на рік.
Натомість ставлення до "Північного потоку-2" у Брюсселя і Берліна різне.
Єврокомісія здебільшого проти подвоєння потужностей
вже наявного газопроводу "Північний потік"
і хоче на своєму рівні вести переговори з Росією.
Німеччина ж наполягає,
що це виключно комерційний проект і
вирішувати його долю мають самі компанії, які беруть в ньому участь.